ok dann können wir anfangen bevor wir
heute uns mit james theorie über das
gute beschäftigen mit seiner frage ob
wir das gut definieren können sie haben
es ja gelesen möchte ich mit ihnen ein
quiz machen und sie haben vielleicht
gesehen ich hatte ihnen das strom
geschickt
wir können es aber trotzdem mal
gemeinsam noch machen wenn sie wollen
also theorien des guten und schauen wir
einfach mal was sie richtig ist also es
gibt hier immer eine oder mehrere
richtige antwort möglichkeiten und die
erste frage lautet welche der folgenden
aussagen ist wahr dass modale mutter des
guten fasst es als eine handlungs
dimension auf was das gute idee dass
grad ua liz tische modell des guten fast
das gute als seins fülle auf see das
polare modell des guten fast das böse
als eine prävention des guten auf die
das graduell ist ische modell fasst das
böse als eine prima zion des guten hv ii
das ist ganz schön schwierig jetzt
dürfen sie sich um einfach melden dürfen
einfach mal tippen oder mal sagen
welches auf jeden fall richtig ist wurde
welches vielleicht auf jeden fall falsch
ist oder können wir gemeinsam überlegen
was die wahren antwortmöglichkeiten sind
wir können einfach mal durch gegen das
moderne modell sitzen damit aus erinnern
sie sich noch
ich habe ja so ein paar modelle
angeboten tafel gemalt ihn dann aber
auch in der zusammenfassung die auch
herum gegangen ist also jetzt von der
letzten sitzung die müssten sie alle
bekommen haben diese modelle versucht
grafisch zu veranschaulichen wie war das
noch mit den modellen modelle
so habe ich es jedenfalls genannt
wissen sie es noch ein
also wir hatten dieses polare modell des
bösen hatten wir gesagt dass die stehen
sich so gegenüber wiso zwei mächte dann
wieso zwei pole von so einem google
nordpol und südpol wie zwei magneten
polen damit gesagt das ist problematisch
so vom bösen zu sprechen
heutzutage das würde bedeuten dass es
das böse irgendwie gibt also jetzt das
böse was hatten wir gesagt werden gesagt
ist es wahrscheinlich oder irgendwie
sinnvoll zu sagen das böse qualifiziert
besondere handlungen es ist nicht etwas
was an sich oder so besteht wie ein polo
oder wie ein macht oder sowas
sondern es ist ein attribut es ist also
ein der eigenschaft von einer handlung
zum beispiel wurde von unseren willen öl
das wir jetzt es modale modellen sieht
es denn damit aus nachdem was jetzt
gesagt wäre es dann richtig
sie nicken
kein ende heute ist
ok genau also es gibt gute und böse
handlungen
das hatte ich das modell genannt also
nicht alle böse als modus unser handeln
als form oder erscheinungsweise unserer
handlung als art unserer handlung okay
wie sie zb ist das realistische modell
des guten fasst es als seins fülle auf
das war diese punkte haben wir gesagt
hier unten hier ist 0
hier geht es immer weiter hoch und es
gut ist entweder da oben oder im
unendlichen schied damit aus
das kapitalistische modell des guten
fast das gute als sainz wieder auf wie
sieht es damit aus
sie nicken
die frage ist nur welche fülle die
unendliche fülle oder eine bestimmte
fülle aber es ist eine fülle könnte man
sagen dass katar liste zeigt dass das
gute ist immer die positiven bereich sie
zahlen mehr als 0 2 c das polare modell
des guten fast das böse als eine
prävention des rotten auf
überlegen sie mal das polare modell war
wieso zwei gegensätze mächten zu
schütteln den kopf
ja wie
sie wird sagen das passt nicht zum
polaren diese also ich würd sagen
privat hat er was mit dem grat zu tun
also das besser nicht an grenzen
ok und wie sieht es mit dem aus das
kapitalistische modell fasst das böse
als eine prävention des guten hoffen
ok also zu sagen einfach
das böse ist ein mangel an guten
analysis 0
oder vielleicht hier im niederen bereich
und die weiter wie hoch kommt desto
besser das ok ja sonst noch einwände
haben sie irgendwelche ergänzenden
meinungen dazu sonst klicke ich jetzt
mal auf senden und wir schauen wo es ist
richtig sehen sie hier richtig
und weiter geht's zweite frage was
charakterisiert macht platz und idee des
guten
sie ist eine reine vorstellung wie sie
steht jenseits des seins sie ist der
inbegriff der nützlichkeit dies ist die
erkenntnis science und werte grund oder
wert gut der ideen immer wieder der
reihe nach durch h wie sieht es damit
aus ist idee des guten eine reine
vorstellung nicht warum nicht hier gerne
dürfen gerne einfach so hinein rufen
[Musik]
13 nicht nur die vorstellen
in jedem gegenstand
genau eine vorstellung wäre ja nur so
napp abbildet die idee ist ja nicht das
abbild und das vorbild ist die idee das
ist das entscheidende
b sie steht jenseits des seins
sie nicken
ja es hat was transzendent ist also es
ist jedenfalls nicht jetzt habe ich ja
schon häkchen gemacht also ist es nicht
mehr das hatten sie ja gemeint an nicht
wie würden sie sagen ja sie ist der
inbegriff der nützlichkeit ja warum
nicht
gleich gesagt glaube ich nicht
das kann sich keiner zu
also platten wäre kein utilitaristischen
sie sei das war doch jon stewart mir
würde es vielleicht zutreffen oder eher
zutreffen aber nicht auf platte um
platte ist kein notiert er ist die sagen
okay okay die sie ist die erkenntnis
science und wertgrund der idee
okay gut
richtig es ist ok hat die man sonst noch
eine begründung oder eine idee warum das
richtig
ok also wir hatten gesagt die idee des
guten ist zieren sich noch an die sonne
des sonnen gleichnis die des guten ist
zu vergleichen mit der sonne die wir
eigentlich nie direkt reinschauen können
die sonne ist für uns kein objekte
erkenntnis sondern sie ist eine
bedingung der erkenntnis oder die sonne
können wir nicht sehen so muss man sagen
die sonne sehen wir eigentlich nicht
wenn wir sie sehen dann bleiben wir am
see schaden dadurch sie ist kein
wirkliches objekt des sehens sondern sie
ist eher das wenige was es uns
ermöglicht objekte zu sehen und dann
kann man sagen in dem die sonne oder das
gute jetzt auf die analogie basis eben
nicht ein objekt ist sondern eine
bedingung für objekte könnte man sagen
es ist die erkenntnis grund dass wir
also ideen oder science erkennen können
sie ist sogar noch mehr sie ist der
science grund der ideen als sie macht es
möglich dass die den wirklich sind und
sie ist der wertgrund der ideen ist
jetzt genannt sie verleiht den ideen
eine bedeutung
oder sie hat sie sorgt dafür dass das
was ist auch wie gut ist glatt von
irgendwie sie ja bestimmt jetzt gesehen
haben neid jetzt zu einem grad
juristischen modell man jetzt sagen
platon hätte eine komparative ontologie
komparative theologie heißt für platter
und gibt es dinge die mehr oder weniger
seien sind sie erinnern sich noch an
dieses linien gleichnis ganz unten waren
die schatten oder des höhengleichen sie
unten sind die schatten ja
und je weiter wir nach oben kommen das
tor
salzhaltige wird das ganze
ok jetzt schauen wir was herauskommt
grund es ist wieder richtig
nächste frage was charakterisiert das
gute nach aristoteles aber es ist das
nützliche bs führt uns zur
glückseligkeit jetzt steht über allen
ideen die es ist lebensweltlich konkret
ist es nützlich wie sieht es damit aus
das weiß ich jetzt selbst nicht mehr
also mal ausprobieren würden sie ihr
nein sagen
jetzt führt uns zur glückseligkeit
ja wissen sie noch mal was
glückseligkeit auf griechisch heißt
daher genau schreibt noch mal hin genau
cs steht überall mit dem
genau dann richtig es nicht zu treffen
und ds ist lebensweltlich konkret würden
sie ihr sagen als aus der kritik an der
platonischen theorie dass das gute
bahnen steht folgt es muss in allem
irgendwie sein wie auch immer jetzt
genau die punkt technologien alles
strebt nach einem guten und es ist
richtig was charakterisiert das gute
note aa das gute ist dass sein wie das
gute steht über dem seien das gute und
das eine sind aufs engste verbunden die
das gute ist der geist das ist schwierig
aus
das gute ist dass sein
nicht hier nicht also wir hatten drei
begriffe bei putin sie haben sich noch
wir hatten das gute agathon wir hatten
das sein und wir hatten das eine das
handy jetzt die frage wie die sich da so
einander verhalten
3 wie sieht's aus ist das gute das sein
sie glauben ja
wir kennen
ich weiß nicht wie das dritte platz dazu
ok
sehen ist die anderen teilnehmer genauso
sehe einen dicken dann versuchen wir es
einfach mal teilweise richtig klicken
sie auf eine beliebige stelle oder
drücken sie hat um fortzufahren
da müssen wir nachher uns mal die
auswertung noch mal anschauen aber wir
sind schon sehr gut also ich glaube
werden es bestehen also noch knapp
nächste frage was charakterisiert das
gute nach thomas von aquin hs steht in
der fülle des seins es besteht in der
fülle des seins bse ist der unter
logische maßstab an dem das schlecht
bemessen werden kann
cs ist eine prävention des bösen die es
wird unter logisch gedacht
thomas von aquin überlegen sie mal ein
wenig im setting tritt der thomas von
aquin auf wie sieht es da aus
si
ist das gute eine prävention des bösen
würden sie sagen
ach so kaya es interessant ja okay so
könnte man es auch sehen
oder ist das ist das böse nicht die alle
privaten des guten
also man kann sie auch zwei sachen
ziehen das gute ist eine prävention des
bösen das blöde ist alle privat ionescu
das wäre jetzt das gute ist eine
präsentation des bösen
das gute ist eine beraubung ein mangel
an bösen das würde bedeuten dass thomas
von aquin
das gute am bösen bemisst der umgedrehte
also eher nicht haben sie sonst noch
irgendwelche ideen was man ankreuzen
kann also das setting ist ihnen klar
thomas von aquin ist zwar einer der sagt
er ist das böse bei null da oben ist das
gut zu überlegen sie mal wenn sie jetzt
dieses ziel vor augen haben welche
antwortmöglichkeiten dann richtig sind
ja
ulrich hocker wie sieht es mit a aus
überlegen sie mal setting hier
es ist gut oben ist alles da und wenn
wir weiter wie herunter kommt desto
schlechter wird das ganze können sie das
noch sehen geht es noch okay es geht
nicht die hängen hier irgendwie dass
diese kaputt glaub ich okay okay dann
machen wir nochmal und jetzt schauen wir
mal ob es geht und es ist richtig werden
nachdem die meint ich dachte die ja die
gehen auch okay alles klar
ok haben wir noch zwei tagen
nächste frage was charakterisiert das
gute nach immanuel kant absolut gut ist
nur der gute wille
vielen dank
die gut
können eigentlich nur maximen genannt
werden das gute für zur glückseligkeit
die das höchste gut ist die
proportionalität von moralität und
glückseligkeit
was charakterisiert das gute nach kant
absolut gut ist nur der gute wille wie
sieht es da aus damit aus wissen sie
doch hat mit was kann diesen guten
willen verglichen hatte
ganz am anfang seiner grundlegung zu
metallisierten hatte eine metapher
es ist vor allem eine kostbarkeit
vielleicht hat der eine oder die antwort
von ihnen sogar so etwas selbst ein
juwel
ich hab kein aber vielleicht jemand von
ihm weiß man ja nie ein erbstück oder
sowas kann man ja mal eben ok 2+ wie gut
können eigentlich nur maximen genannt
werden sind sie schütteln den kopf
aus
heute
klar
den abschluss
max 7 sind aber nicht nur regeln zur
maxime sind willens regeln also regeln
unseres willens wie sieht es dann aus
wenn sie überlegen was sind maxim wachs
maxime sind grundsätze ihres handelns
man kann sich jetzt vor allem sind
grundsätze des handelns nicht mit dem
willen sehr eng verwandt oder sogar das
selten und mit unseren finden
vielleicht ist nicht genau dasselbe aber
ich denke es geht die selbe richtung und
ich glaube wir können es ankreuzen
es geht eben nicht um handlungen dass es
entscheidend wie das gute für zur
glückseligkeit
nicht warum nicht auch keine gründe sind
sie sagen es ist konnte ein tief ist
richtig wie sieht es mit dem aus das
höchste gut ist die proportionalität von
moralität und glückseligkeit
ja sie nicken klingt gut irgendwie oder
das wäre was wieder haben sie daher war
das meldung nicht
ja
das gut
wer gezielt ein
ja sie hat genau sie hatten sie noch
gemeint würden sie ist ähnliches sagen
wie die kommilitonen
ja wenn die kommilitonin sagt das hat
damit was zu tun dann wird es
wahrscheinlich stimmen jetzt versuchen
versuchen wir es einfach mal ob's stimmt
ist richtig als lohn sie das höchste gut
mit kant in verbindung zu bringen das
ist ein wichtiges lehrstück aus ganz
philosophie haben noch eine frage und
zwar was charakterisiert das gute nach
wäre sonst wird mir das gute ist etwas
transzendente svi das gute bemisst sich
an der größten nützlichkeit für alle die
das wahre gute besteht in der
kultivierten lust die alles was die
eigene glückseligkeit steigert ist gut
es sieht gut aus ist das gute etwas
transzendente nach john stuart mill
sie schütteln kopf nicht bei wem wäre
das gut etwas transparentes wissen sie
es noch fragen alle wer sagt das gut ist
etwas transzendente
der parkplatz ist das gute bemisst sich
in den größten nützlichkeit für alle
boote die tourismus ist die position als
wahre gute besteht in der kultivierten
lust den kopf
wieso
wie stehen sie dazu
es ist schwierig
ja
genau die kopie korea die würden halt
sagen luststeigerung irgendwie ein
bisschen schon ein bisschen
problematisch ist das war gut was ist
das waren gut aber gute wieder lust ist
hier das stichwort und alles was die
eigene glückseligkeit steigert ist gut
richtig
ja genau und dem steht auch b entgegen
wir hatten ja eh schon angekreuzte ging
es um die größte möglichkeit für alle
aber natürlich wenn es um einen selbst
geht dann kann man schon sagen wir
müssen da auch selbst lust empfinden
aber nicht irgendeine sondern die
höchstmögliche und das ist nicht eine
graduelle modell sondern es ist ein
qualitatives mit denn es geht also nicht
darum das jetzt hier 04 maximum lust wir
müssen ganz hoch kommen sondern wir
müssen einfach die höchste qualität
erreichen
wir müssen einfach sein ein modernes
modell von lust wie also qualifizierten
ostasien höher als tiger sein
kultivierter lust oder mehr punkte ok
und ist es auch richtig und jetzt
schauen wir uns mal die auswertung an
wir haben es also bestanden sie sehen
wir haben bestanden mit 93 75 jetzt
gehen wir zum quiz überprüfen
keine frage war nicht eine sache war
nicht ganz klar
also die erste war richtig zweiter war
richtig dritte war richtig hier ja was
keine klassik macht's gut nach platin
also wir hatten ja angekreuzt das gute
ist dass sein das war falsch sie hatten
wir angekreuzt das war richtig das gute
und das einzelne aufs engste verbunden
das gute steht über dem seien wären noch
wirklich werden richtig gewesen also bei
kloten ist es so wir haben hier das gute
und das eine und darunter kommt dass
sein und der geist das ist alles
übergeordnet das gute und das eine
stimme dem geist und dem sein das ist
bei piloten
wir hatten uns überlegt womit das
zusammenhängt was der grund dafür ist
es scheint dass das gute über den zaun
steht
und deswegen ist auch die falsch das
gute ist der geist das ist falsch das
ist die ordnung ungefähr bei pro team ok
die restlichen fragen hatten wir richtig
beantwortet sie können christian noch
mal zu hause für sich machen
wir wollen wenn sie vorher freiwillig
okay dann haben wir jetzt eine kleine
wiederholung gemacht und jetzt können
wir zum nächsten denker übergehend zu gm
das war ein britischer philosoph sie
sehen wir kommen jetzt von mir ganz
dicht in die gegenwart hinein hat er
geschrieben principia ethiker also die
prinzipien der ethik und
zudem muss ich folgendes sagen der ist
ein sprachphilosoph nicht so sehr wie
jetzt platten oder andere ökologische
fragen stellen also was ist das gute mit
seinem seien nach oder wie sollen wir
handeln erkannt mäßig was ist der wille
sondern gefragt wie verwenden überhaupt
das wort unter dem begriff gut das ist
sogar allgemeine tendenz der
sprachphilosophie bevor wir uns über den
gehalt gedanken machen oder über die den
gegenstand beginnen zu diskutieren
sollten wir uns überhaupt über erst mal
überlegen wie wir das wort gebrauchen
und das macht jetzt die eu also er
befasst sich jetzt mit der bedeutung von
gut fragt können wir das gute definieren
sie sehen ja das hatten wir auch schon
hier in der ersten ersten sitzung gesagt
gut ist sehr viel deutet also es hat
mindestens zwei bedeutung des wortes
kann bedeutend zur wie angenehm
glückseligkeit harmoniert diese ganze
seite ist da drin aber auch diesen
engeren moralischen sinn gutes moralisch
gut und
sie knüpft an diese vieldeutigkeit des
wortes an und steht damit wie wir sehen
werden dann in einer gewissen nähe
auch sehen sie nur sprachphilosophie
schon nicht unter logisch ist zu
plattform
das ist ganz erstaunlich zu platon und
wir wollen jetzt uns mal die leitfragen
ansehen also wie finden unterscheidet
sich nach 10 uhr die semantik semantik
ist die bedeutung der bedeutung von gut
von begriffen wie gelb und pferd das
andere begriffe nächste frage inwiefern
sind aussagen über das gute synthetisch
synthetisches zusammengesetzt analytisch
wer der gegenbegriff würde bedeuten dass
endlich enthalten bringt der aussage
enthalten
er kommt hinzu dass wäre analytisch
nächste frage warum kann gut nicht
definiert werden das ist die wichtigste
frage für uns zu diesem sitzung heute
und dann noch etwas versteht nur unter
einem naturalistischen fehlschluss ist
auch ein ganz wichtiger begriff
naturalistische fehlschluss bedeutet
letztendlich man versucht das gute an
übernatürliche prädikate oder solche
prädikate wie das angenehm zu bestimmen
sie sehen schon dass das nicht problem
deswegen ist weil das gute die nur
natürliche oder
angenehme seiten also angenehme
definitions merkmale hat die das
angenehme bedeuten sondern immer auch
darüber hinaus geht das problem also
begriff des guten der ist konstitutiv
ambivalent könnte man sagen er hat diese
seite das angenehme und die seite des
moralischen und die frage ist einfach
die wie verhalten sich sein und sollen
zueinander als wie verhalten sich jetzt
endlich oder dass das sein kann auch
sagen natur und das gut
wie verhalten die sich zu einer können
wir das gute das sollen also dass sollen
es die pflicht das was moralisch geboten
ist moralische normen können wir die aus
der natur aus dem sein ableiten das
würde ich sie gerne auch noch kurz mal
fragen weil das wird in der nächsten
sitzung noch sehr wichtig werden
also würden sie sagen dass die natur das
seien natur wäre es aber eine einfache
ein engerer bereich des seins es gibt ja
auch sein dass was nicht natürlich ist
zum beispiel computer computer oder
sowas oder irgendwas anderes aber sagt
fassen dass wir mal jetzt mal sehr eng
würden sie sagen dass wir aus den ohren
dem sein gibt es der welt wie sie ist
irgendetwas daraus folgt wie etwas
anderes sein sollte als wir vom seien
zum sollen übergehen können haben sie da
eine idee
wie könnten sie irgendeinen sollen
begründen auf basis der natur wie
könnten sie eine moralische normen
gewinnen indem sie die natur betrachten
wie verfolgt aus natur ein sollen haben
sie da eine idee
wie könnte man dann versuchen aus natur
irgendwelche normen moralischer art
abzuleiten
denken sie doch mal tierschutz oder
sowas tierschutz da also gut ist das
selige ja
als aus dem sein der verfasstheit von
tieren ihre nahrungsaufnahme folgt das
alles was in natürlichen gleichgewicht
bleibt sondern dieser kreislauf nah
dieses die wieder typische kreislauf
dass das wie gut ist also eine
normativität hat normativität meint
immer dieses sollen diese wertung und
das alles was diesen natürlichen die
natürliche ordnung zerstört oder in
gefahr bringt dass das schlecht ist dass
während was man sagt hier gegenwärtigen
diskussion dieser übergang der geht
eigentlich nicht
seit david hume das ist ein empirisches
wir können nicht vom seien auf sollen
schließen
das sind zwei ganz verschiedene sphären
aber es wird immer wieder versucht aus
der welt wie sie ist
aussagen ab so leiden oder regeln
abzuleiten
das sollen betreffen die eine normative
dimension haben und die mur ist eine der
hat diesen begriff geprägt diesen
materialistischen fehlschluss also gut
können wir nicht normative prädikat die
können wir nicht über deskriptive oder
naturalistische natürlich bestimmt
beschreibbare prädikate angemessen
definieren das geht nicht da gibt es
guten der ist viel zu komplex da geht
darüber hinaus
und wir werden den nächsten sitzungen
sehen da lesen wir von viele paar food
einem auf einen auszug aus ihrem buch
der heißt die das heißt die natur des
guten und für die paar foto die these
vertreten dass wir tatsächlich aus die
natürlichen verhaltensweisen das gute
ableiten können
die sagt also es gibt keine kluft
zwischen sein und sollen die würde diese
diese verbindung zu lassen
aber viele philosophen und philosophin
bestreiten dass das wir vom von der welt
wie sie ist die wir beschreiben können
das skript tief etwas normatives gibt es
in zwei verschiedenen sphären das was
sein soll was das gefordert ist und dass
wie es ist es gibt doch immer wieder
versuche beide zusammenzubringen das ist
intuition wir wollen aus dem seien auch
irgendwas über das sollen gewinnen bei
platon war es ganz einfach platt und
sagt ja die idee des guten die ist halt
sowohl der science als auch der werte
grund wie ich ihn genannt hat die welt
darin zitiert dass sein und der wert bei
platin es ist ein bisschen anders blut
ihn sagt die normativität das gute stück
über dem sein sie haben sich das hatten
wir gerade hier das recht stets nur die
normativität steht über dem seien
interessante plattform konzipiert das
sei mit dem sollen in der idee des guten
bzw platt und sagt eigentlich die idee
des guten ist gar kein sein sind sie ist
jenseits des seins aber sie ist der
science grund der erkenntnis kommunen
der werte grund alle dessen was
existiert also ist ein riesen frage wie
das sein dass sollen miteinander
zusammenhängen das betrifft natürlich
auch die frage nach dem guten mann kann
jetzt aber noch dazu folgendes anführen
dass gute der begriff des guten hat
immer und auch schon im antiken
griechenland inbegriff des agathon was
heißt gut immer auch mit deskriptive
seite also eine nicht natürlich also
eine natürliche seite gewissermaßen also
gut bedeutet nach dem griechischen
begriff immer dieses wohlergehen daher
hat es hat diese dimension des
angenehmen und die dimensionen des
moralischen und deswegen könnte man
sagen der ursprüngliche begriff des
guten hat immer eine deskriptive und
innovative seite in sich da ist nicht so
rein normativ wie viele viele lesen oder
gelesen haben
und auch bei thomas von der queen haben
sie gesehen das gute und das sollen das
ist einfach nur eine steigerung des
seins die mehr sein wir haben desto mehr
sonnen haben wir zwar dieses
charakteristische modell hatte war ganz
oben hier ist 0
und hier war irgendwo das gut da war die
die skala so erreicht hier also ist
jedes sonne und das gut also sein und
sollen sind eine graduelle realistischen
verhältnis zu land also man sieht die
ganze geschichte philosophie hat das
gute und das sein dass sollen und die
natur immer wieder in ein verhältnis
gebracht
es war nie so dass die ganz getrennt
voneinander existieren aber systeme uns
sehr problematisches verhältnis und
jetzt war man einfach mal hier loslegen
mit diesem text was jetzt die uhr über
den status des wortes des begriffs des
guten sein sagt gut ist also sofern wir
damit die eigenschaften die wir einem
ding zu schreiben dass wir mit gut
bezeichnen im entscheidenden sinne des
wortes keine definition fähig der
entscheidende sinn von definition ist
derjenige wonach eine definition
feststeht wie ich es die teile sind die
unveränderlich ein bestimmtes ganzes
bilden und in diesem sinne entzieht sich
jeglicher definition das einfach ist und
keine teile hat es ist einer jener
zahllosen gegenstand des denkens die
selbstdefinition wohl fähig sind weil
sie die letzte begriffe sind mit denen
alles was definierbar ist definiert
werden muss
dass es eine unbestimmte zahl solcher
begriffe gibt wird beim nachdenken klar
denn wir können lediglich durch analyse
definieren die uns bei konsequenter
weiterführung auf etwas verwaist das
einfach verschiedene von allen übrigen
ist und durch diesen letzten unterschied
die eigenart des ganzen das wir
definieren erklärt denn jedes ganz
enthält einige teile die es mit anderen
ganzen gemeinsam hat es erhebt sich also
keine grundsätzliche schwierigkeit gegen
die these dass gut eine einfache und
definierbare eigenschaft bezeichnet es
gibt viele andere beispiele solcher
eigenschaften was sagte jetzt über gut
warum kann es gut nicht definiert werden
es war also eigentlich mal wieder drauf
betroffen ist
würde
draußen
menschen
es war aber aus bezeichnet werden das
gute verständnis effektiven das gesetz
ich denke es geht auf jeden fall die
richtige richtung sie wollen sie noch
mehr
wie auch
deswegen können
und er sagt noch was wichtig ist weil es
die letzten begriffe sind hier die
letzten begriffe mit denen alles was
definierbar ist definiert werden muss
also ein grundbegriffe nicht mehr weiter
analysiert barren grundbegriff flog
leuchtet ja ein definieren oder
analysieren heißt wir gliedern ein
komplexes in seine teile
wenn wir ein komplexes wissen zu
unendlich immer weiter teilen könnten
dann würden wir es nicht definieren
können bekäme immer wieder einen punkt
den man weiter analysieren könnte und so
weiter und so fort
das heißt wir müssen beim definieren
analysieren von begriffen irgendwann auf
grundbegriffe stoßen anhand deren wie es
dann erklären und hier sagt jetzt simor
ist das gute ein solcher letzter begriff
leuchtet ja eigentlich recht ein dass
wir sehr gut ist ein zentraler begriff
vielleicht wieder das böse mit dem wir
einfach so umgehen dass wir nicht noch
weiter zurückführen wollen auf etwas
anderes
also sie sehen hier knüpft eigentlich an
diese frage auch an die bei protein sich
gestellt hat steht das gute über dem
sein oder unter dem 2 1
wie stets damit diese frage dass eine
der geist und so weiter sofort und er
würde sagen wie blut oder wie platon das
gute steht über den anderen irgendwie
semantisch jetzt natürlich nicht unter
logische edition die definition also
müsse sprach philosophische dimension
es ist einfach und hat keine teile
überlegen sie mal hat das gute der
begriff des guten teile oder gehen wir
mal anders aus definieren sie mal pferd
oder so fährt wie definieren sie pferd
hat die definition verkehrt teile
genau genommen kann es auch mal kann es
auch dann vororten also es gehört dieser
gattung an dieser art an säugetiere
so genoss proxim um differenzen
spezifika haben sie bestimmt schon
gehört also das nächste die nächste
gattin und die spezifische differenz als
wir unterscheiden das pferd von anderen
arten die es noch gibt von säugetieren
ich weiß nicht vielleicht von hunden und
so weiter von menschen und dann hamma
nächst höhere gattung das ist säugetier
vielleicht gut wenn man genau hinschaut
die gibt's noch paarhufer und was ich
also es ist jetzt nicht ganz korrekt was
ich gesagt habe wir bringen sie in einem
verhältnis gibt noch eine höhere gattung
jedenfalls säugetiere gibt es in eine
höhere gattung als das gute sind die
frage das wäre ja meine definition
notwendig dass wir eine höhere gattung
angeben oder eine art damit eine art was
mir einfallen würde wäre das sagen es
ist eine moralische kategorie also eine
andere art wäre noch das böse oder böse
fallen unter eine höhere datum
h
das wäre noch möglich aber ansonsten gut
zu definieren wie man ein pferd
definieren kann als im schweif vier
beine kann man das beim guten zu sagen
das gute und das pferd
da könnte jetzt höchstens sagen wie
würde john stuart mill würde es
analysieren erweitert wie würde mittels
analysierendes gute
überlegen sie doch mal an die letzte
sondern die letzte sitzung wir hatten es
ja heute schon behandeln was sagt mir
ist das gute
könnte erst dann definieren wir jetzt
das gute
si
die würde er es machen wie würde er es
versuchen zu machen
[Musik]
genau
er würde seine kalkulation machen
wahrscheinlich würde sagen also diese
handlung hat die meisten positiven
effekte für die größte anzahl von
menschen gehabt würde erst
quantifizieren
also mir würde es vielleicht anders
sehen würde sagen wir können das gute
schon irgendwie genauer analysieren
durch den nutzen und ist angenehm was
dass die handlungen mit sich geführt
haben so die möglichkeit ok jedenfalls
sagt nur sein landsmann es geht nicht
und jetzt bringt ein anderes beispiel
woran ehrt seine these erläutern möchte
dass das gute nicht weit analysierbar
ist nehmen sie zum beispiel gelb wir
können versuchen es durch die
beschreibung seines physikalischen
äquivalenz zu definieren
wir können feststellen was für licht
schwingungen das normale augen reizen
müssen damit wir es wahrnehmen aber eine
kurze überlegung genügt um zu zeigen
dass diese licht schwingungen selbst
nicht das sind was er mit gelb meine sie
sind es nicht die wir wahrnehmen ja wir
hätten ihre existenz niemals entdecken
können wenn uns nicht so vor der
offenbare qualitative unterschied
zwischen verschiedenen farben
aufgefallen wäre
wir können allenfalls sagen dass diese
schwingungen das sind was den raum was
im raum dem von uns wirklich
wahrgenommen gelb entspricht
wie viel kann man jetzt das gute mit der
farbe gelb oder mit gelb vergleichen
überlegen sie mit der hinsicht der
definition können sie gelb definieren
indem sie geld in weitere teile auflösen
inwiefern hat gelb und mut inwiefern
haben eine gemeinsamkeit passiv
analysierbar kaikante land
zusätzlich können
das werden die möglichkeit so könnte man
das interpretieren denken sie aber
nochmal an diese farbe gelb finden sie
jetzt eine ganz homogene farbe gelb vor
sich sehen oder da ist können sie dann
dieses geld so definieren dass sie
jemanden erklären was gibt es denn noch
nie gelb gesehen hat das müssen sie ja
überlegen so ein bisschen ich glaube so
kann sich das gut vorstellen jemandem zb
blinkt ist können sie dem geld durch
definition näher bringen verständlich
machen
es ist wichtig zu sagen dass es um den
gemeinsinn
mit dem höchsten
sie hätten wir noch andere farben
jedenfalls wobei wird dadurch ja nicht
wenn wir jetzt das böse noch anführen
damit können wir natürlich nicht dass
gute definieren wir können höchstens
sagen das gegenteil davon
aber damit erklären wir eigentlich nicht
was es ist sie hatten sie noch gemeint
ich würde den wert ist wenn man es
versuchen würde zu erklären
mein geld reicht von den berg
wenn man trotzdem irgendwie so genannten
gelten
konkreter werden
haben
bayern
wir haben
als mit vergleichen mit beispielen die
frage wer hat ob das dann noch eine
definition wer es wäre so eine hilfe den
begriff näher zu kommen aber eigentlich
dafür zu einem strengen sinne wird
vielleicht nicht mehr als wir so eine
aus dem hinteren man könnte sich
höchstens darüber lägen mit solchen
komplementärfarben und als zugabe gibt
es ja so verschiedene verhältnisse ich
habe sie jetzt nicht im kopf haben
einander irgendwie konstituieren
dass die sich gegenseitig entsprechen
gewissen mischverhältnisse zwar noch
möglich haben sie müssen mit dem geld
wenn sie das geld nicht gesehen haben
wirklich wie können sie es sie können
diese qualität das gelb vereins nur ganz
schlecht definiert gelb ist ein wie man
auch nennt ein quad also keine quelle
sind an quale hier natürlich das heißt
ein wie zustand wie es ist gelb zu sein
diesen gelb eindruck den sie haben den
können sie nur ganz schwer richtig
beschreiben sie können ich sagen der ist
1 meter 80 groß oder so und so schwer
das geht nicht wir müssen es gesehen
haben genauso wie mit schmerzen zurück
märz können sie auch mit metaphern
beschreiben ein beißender schmerz ein
stechender schmerz ein kochender schmerz
und so weiter wie es ist diesen schmerz
zu haben das geht eigentlich nur wenn
man ihn selbst erlebt ich denke diese
richtung geht es nun das eben nicht
analysierbar ist
okay ist einfach weiter und doch ist ein
solch simpler fehler entdeckt auf gut
weit verbreitet es mag sein dass alle
dinge die gut sind auch etwas anderes
sind sowie alle dinge die gelb sind eine
gewisse art der licht schwingung
hervorrufen und es steht fest dass die
ethik entdecken will welches diese
anderen eigenschaften sind die allen
dingen die gut sind zu kommen aber viel
zu viele philosophen haben gemeint dass
sie wenn sie diese anderen eigenschaften
nennen tatsächlich gut definieren dass
diese eigenschaft in wirklichkeit nicht
anderes sein sondern absolut und
vollständig gleichbedeutend mit gut halb
goldenes diese an sich möchte ich den
naturalistischen fehlstunden und ihm
werde ich nun abzuhandeln versuchen
ok jetzt haben wir ein ganz
interessanten passagen was bis jetzt
nachdem uhr unter einem naturalistischen
fehlschluss zu verstehen
was für eine ansicht
ihren versuchen eigenschaften sind
um zinsen
und schließen daraus dass
genau
denn
genau wann haben sie die was das bei gut
sein könnte er sagt das noch aber jetzt
nicht in diesem zitat was können wir das
bei gut sein
also was begleicht alles gute
das darf sonst
das wird
aber was können wir zum beispiel dieses
beispiel sein also worin könnte dieser
fehler bestehen diese materialistische
fehlschluss in welcher fälschlichen
definition des guten könnte der bestehen
also was müsste ich im grunde jung führt
das gute halten um zu diesem fehlschuss
zu gelangen
denken sie an john stuart mill mal
wieder ein bisschen das nützliche genau
das angenehm
das wäre für ihn nur wie wir gleich noch
sehen werden so die naturalisten des
trierer fehlschluss also vom vom vom
nützlichen nützlich
und nicht auf gut gut oder auch angenehm
vom angenehmen auf das gute zu schließen
ok
er sagte ohne ersten zeile es mag sein
dass alle dinge die gut sind auch etwas
anders sind sowie alle dinge die gelb
sind in gewisser art der licht eine
gewisse art der lichtschein hervorrufen
aber viel zu viele viele suchen haben
gemeint dass sie wenn sie diese anderen
eigenschaften wenn tatsächlich gut
definieren
also man könnte das so sekundär umstände
nennen oder ip phänomene das ist also
phänomene die darauf voll aber es sind
nicht die eigentlichen wesentlich
definierenden bestandteile okay so
einfach mal weiter
nehmen wir an jemand sagt ich empfinde
ich lust und nehmen wir an es ist weder
lüge noch youtube sondern die wahrheit
nun wenn es wahr ist was bedeutet es
bedeutet dass sein geist ein gewisser
bestimmter geist von allen anderen durch
gewisse bestimmte kennzeichen
unterschieden in diesem augenblick ein
gewisses bestimmtes gefühl hat genannt
lustlos dem film bedeutet nichts anderes
als lust haben
und obgleich man mehr oder weniger lust
empfinden uns sogar wie wir vorläufig
einräumen dürfen die ein oder andere art
von lust haben können klammer sie john
stuart mill
so hat man doch hin so fängt das was man
sagt lust ist ob mehr oder weniger oder
von der einen oder anderen art etwas
bestimmtes absolut definierbares etwas
was dasselbe ist und all den
verschiedenen stufen und in all den
verschiedenen arten die möglich sind
vielleicht kann man angeben wie es mit
anderen dingen zusammenhängt dass es zum
beispiel im geist ist dass es begierde
verursacht dass man sich zwar bewusst
ist und so weiter
man kann wie gesagt seine beziehung zu
anderen dingen beschreiben aber
definieren kann man es nicht
also hier bringt jetzt diese konkrete
beispiel also lust bedeutet das
dass dieses lustempfinden das gut
definiert
also lust empfinden kann nichts mir
jetzt hier neulich
irgendwie etwas uns über das gute sagen
dass das problem
und jetzt sagt genauso mit lust lust ist
ob mehr oder weniger oder von denen der
ein oder anderen art etwas bestimmtes
absolut definierbares etwas was das
serie ist in allen verschiedenen stufen
und all den verschiedenen arten die
möglich sind also lust scheint ganz
ähnlich zu sein wie das gute es ist auch
nicht mehr weiter definierbar
und das ist ich kann's definieren ich
kann nicht mal vorstellen
wenn wir jetzt die farbe gelb wie jetzt
waren es ist auch
fragen des lands ich weiß
genau
also es geht in diese richtung wir
müssen gelb gesehen haben wir müssen
lust empfunden haben wir müssen das gute
als betrifft haben letztendlich diesen
begriff bestimmen zu können wir können
ihn nicht definieren über andere
begriffe ein bisschen ganz angewiesen
auf diese nur begriff könnte man ein
quader ist also ein subjektiver
bewusstseinszustand das gelb sehen ein
schmerzen finden oder lust empfinden uns
aber sofort das geht in sich selbst auf
das hat keine teile mehr die man weiter
analysieren könnte es nimmt unser ganzes
bewusstsein ein könnte man sagen
so würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen
dass ja das würde ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt sagen no mechanismus würde
sagen alle begriffe sind nur annahmen
sind abstraktionen das während andere
fragestellungen ich glaube dass es damit
nicht kriegt ja aber was sie sagen ist
glaube ich richtig so ein quader als ein
wie zustand der ist als solcher nicht
mehr weiter definierbare geht ganz in
diesem wie auch wie es ist geld zu sehen
wie es ist ein schmerz zu haben
der schmerz hat keine teile mehr
wirklich er hat so was letztes an sich
so würde ich jetzt mal interpretieren
wir müssen wir weiter lesen das jetzt
noch nicht ganz hundertprozentig klar
und wenn jemand versuchte lust für uns
als irgendeinen anderen natürlichen
gegenstand zu definieren wenn jemand zum
beispiel sagen würde lust bedeutet die
empfindung von rot und er würde daraus
folgern dass die lust eine farbe zeise
dürften wir ihn auslachen und seinen
weiteren äußerung über die lust
misstrauen
das wäre aber derselbe irrtum den ich
die naturalistischen fehlschluss genannt
habe
das lustempfinden nicht die empfindung
von roth haben oder sonst etwas bedeutet
hindert uns nicht daran zu verstehen was
es bedeutet und was bedeutet uns genug
zu wissen das lustempfinden software
bedeutet wie die empfindung von lust
haben und obwohl die lust absoluten
definierbar ist obwohl lust lust ist und
sonst gar nichts fällt es uns doch nicht
schwer zu sagen dass wir lust empfinden
der grund ist natürlich dass ich mit ich
empfinde lust einfließt nicht meine ich
sei derselbe wie lustig finden ebenso
wenig sollte es schwerfallen zusagen
lust ist gut
ohne damit sie meinen dass lust dasselbe
ist wie gut das lust so viel bedeute wie
gut und gut so viel bedeute wie lust
also was ist jetzt das problem das gute
über lust zu definieren was ist das
problem
er bringt eine analogie in den ersten
beiden sätzen alles sagen lust ist das
gute das wäre genau dasselbe zu sagen
wenn man sagen wir lust bedeutet die
empfindung von roth oder anders gesagt
rot empfindet die bedeutung ist die
bedeutung von geld das so was ist das
problem
das problem ist dass wir offensichtlich
ist damit mit zu homogenen qualitäten zu
tun haben wie mit zur grundformen würde
ich was die haben ihnen sich keine
weiteren teilen ja wir können die nicht
aufeinander zurückführen diese
verschiedenen qualitäten also nicht so
dass hier noch hier noch so ein weiterer
teil es sind eigentlich so was
das geht nicht die sind also ganz in
sich homogen
wir können die nicht aufeinander
zurückführen das geht nicht
eigentlich müsste ich sie schwarz machen
internet sie müsste sie wirklich das ist
so machen
es ist jetzt mal das gute das ist die
lust das rote s sind formen die nicht
einander über für ba sind so muss man
sich das vorstellen
ihr könnt das nicht auseinander
definieren
oder definieren wäre vielleicht besser
definieren genau genommen
also ich muss ich muss rot muss ich
einfach sehen dass das rot geht im sehen
auf in dieser sinnlichen qualität also
diese ist ein brot eindruck und das ist
ein quartal hatten wir schon sagt wie
zustand sagt das gute ist ganz ähnlich
das gute ist auch so was ein urzustand 1
uhr phänomen was nicht weiter
zurückzuführen ist auf andere dinge wie
zb lust ein grundbegriff ein normativer
begriff ein grundbaustein und zwar
sprache vielleicht das gute
also ein ganz banaler ganz banaler
begriff da ist sicherlich was rannten
was dran
also wenn sie jetzt gut mal definieren
wollten
wie würden sie denn versuchen anders
gefragt versuchen sie doch mal gut zu
definieren würden sie das machen
unter dem begriff des guten näher zu
kommen
ich meine es gibt durchaus die
möglichkeit man kann zum beispiel sagen
das gute hat den hat etwas vorzügliches
also etwas etwas normativ ist das besser
sei als eine wertung könnte man sagen
ist drin
die wertung
gut es wird ja ok wertung ist gut das
ist irgendwie doch ein in sich sehr
homogenes phänomen ist nicht jetzt
weitere teile hat es ist so ein grund
begriff einfach des guten
dann ist es vielleicht auch nicht könnte
man noch sagen es ist jetzt nichts was
wirklich den status hat von objekten mit
tische das gute den tisch so in dieser
art sind es gute scheint irgendwie
außerhalb dieser ordnung des
gegenständlichen zu stehen sind das gute
ist dasjenige mit dem wir gegenstände
bewerten können also das gute das
prädikat gut das erlaubt es uns
bestimmte dinge die es gibt die wir
definieren können zu bewerten in der
welt das gute scheint als sie jetzt im
weiteren schluss könnten wir sagen
nachdem wir plattform gelesen haben dass
gute scheint jetzt nichts zu sein wenn
jetzt das die welt ist dass jetzt die
welt die welt ist dass das ist die welt
das gute ist nicht hier drin so
das ist nicht das falsche vorstellung
dass das gute etwas ist was in der welt
vorkommt sind das gute ist irgendwas was
außerhalb steht so wie hier mit dem wir
jetzt endlich dinge die in der welt sind
damit qualifizieren können als es
letztendlich
ein tanz zentraler begriff so nennt man
das also auch so entstand ein
transzendentaler bild er ist die
bedingung der möglichkeit für die
bewertung von gegenständen er ist aber
selbst kein gegenstück das gute ist
selbst kein objekt sind das gute ist ein
maßstab mit dem wir objekte bewerten so
muss man sagen denken sie zurück an die
sonne kommen jetzt wieder hier auf platt
und zurückbleibt und sagt die sonne ist
kein gegenstand in wir sehen können wenn
die sonne ist eine bedingung ist ein
grund die sonne ist der grund dafür dass
wir sehen können genauso könnte man
sagen ist das gute eben nicht entgegen
stand den wir bewerten ist die bedingung
dafür dass wir werden können
ein bisschen dieser art als wollte ich
nur damit sei das hat einen ganz anderen
stadtfestes gute als es zum beispiel
jetzt der begriff des tisches hat
wir können sagen das pferd ist gut aber
dann denken wir das gute nicht so als ob
das gut
gute neben dem pferd in der welt
existieren würden also wir können jetzt
sagen hier dass das pferd fährt und das
ist gut so sagen das pferd ist gut dann
tun machen wir nichts so was dass wir
sagen das gute in der welt das gut wird
auf das pferden der welt bezogen
wir sagen wir qualifizieren das pferd
mit etwas was ein maßstab ist er aber
nicht in der welt so vorkommt wie das
pferd vorkommt und da sehen das hat
durchaus was von platon also dass die
idee des guten ist irgendwie jedenfalls
des seins es ist jetzt nicht sein dass
typischen sinne sondern es ist etwas mit
dem wir das seien die qualifizieren
können
wieso ein maßstab so können sich das
vorstellen ein mann starb oder ein
kriterium existiert nicht sowie
gegenstände existieren die wir
kritisieren können oder bewerten können
das sechste mal starb existiert auf
einer anderen ebene wie die dinge an
denen wir den maßstab anlegen
so kann man sagen in dieser art würde
ich empfehlen das zu verstehen das gute
bei also zwei punkte also erst einmal es
ist nicht so mäder weltlich wie es dinge
sind die transzendentale und zweitens
ist ein grund begriff der sie nicht so
definieren lässt analysieren das wie es
sich begriffe wie sich begriffe
analysieren lassen die sonst in der welt
vorkommen wie pferd oder soweit
anzufordern
leese weiter wenn ich mir ein bild mit
meinem satz ich empfinde lust
auszudrücken ich sei genau dasselbe wie
lustempfinden dann würde ich das
allerdings nicht einen naturalistischen
fehlschluss nennen wenn es auch derselbe
film schluss wäre den ich im hinblick
auf die ethik naturalistisch genannt
habe
der grund hierfür liegt auf der hand
wenn jemand zwei natürliche dinge
miteinander verwechselt indem er das
eine durch das andere definiert wer zum
beispiel sich selbst der eine natürliche
gegenstand ist mit lust empfinden oder
lust jedenfalls natürliche oder lust
ebenfalls natürlichen gegenständen
verwechselt so besteht kein grund den
fehlschluss naturalistisch zu nehmen
wenn aber gut welches nicht im selben
sind ein natürlicher gegenstand ist mit
irgendeinem natürlichen gegenstand
verwechselt dann besteht grund von einem
naturalistischen fehlschluss zu sprechen
dass dies in bezug auf gut geschieht er
weiß es als etwas ganz besonderes und
diese besondere fehler verdient einen
namen weiter verbreitet ist
hier sagt er jetzt wenn er aber gut in
diesem satz den er aber gut welches
nicht dieselben sind natürlich
gegenstand ist wie just also gut hier
sehen sie ist kein natürlicher
gegenstand lust das deutet wieder darauf
hin dass gut nicht diesen selben status
hat die pferde oder alles was in der
welt vorkommen dass gut liegt irgendwie
als ein maßstab außerhalb dieser welt
die bewerber ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit von bewährt barkeit es ist
kein objekt das bewertbar ist bekannt zu
können die zum vzbv ist gut gut das wäre
sinnlos
ob das gute gut ist dass gute schlecht
sein kann und so weiter also das ist
einfach so diese diese dieses maßstabs
charakter wir müssen weiter lesen noch
es handelt sich um einen wirklich
simplen fehlschluss bei diesen
naturalistischen fehlschluss wenn wir
sagen dass eine apfelsine gelb ist
nehmen wir nicht an unsere aussage
zwingen uns zu der behauptung apfelsine
bedeutet nichts anders als gelb oder es
können nichts gelb sein außer der apfel
sie nehmen wir an die aktie ist auch süß
verpflichtet uns das zu behaupten es sei
genau der serbe gelb süß müsse als geld
definiert werden und eine genommen man
erkennt an dass gelb nur gelb main und
sonst nichts erschwert das irgendwie die
ansicht dass apfelsinen gelb sind gewiss
nicht im gegenteil es wäre völlig
sinnlos sagen apfelsinen sein gebt mir
nicht gelb letzten endes nur gelb und
nichts anderes bedeutete falls es nicht
völlig undefinierbar wäre würden
keinerlei klaren begriff von dingen die
games sind bekommen wir würden mit
unserer wissenschaft nicht weiterkommen
wenn wir glauben müssten das alles was
gäbe es genau dasselbe bedeutet wie gut
es sich herausstellt dass wir dann eine
apfelsine für dasselbe wie ein stück
papier eine zitrone sonst irgendetwas
halten müssten wir könnten die
absurdesten dinge beweisen aber wären
wir der wahrheit näher
wo besteht ist das problem ist ein
bisschen schwierig dieses zitates
gewesen
was ist jetzt das problem
wir werden das beispiel wenn es kalt ist
und umgekehrt
ist man aber gefahr
genau
genau das ist diese frage wo ich sage
eine apfelsine ist gelb dann ist dieses
ist nicht einmal der identität zu
verstehen natürlich kann das sei mit
verschiedenen sinne verstehen sind der
identität entzündet dass der pre die
kation also er meint offensichtlich ist
ist hier prädikat ihf zu verstehen
die apfelsine hat die eigenschaft gibt
sei die farbe geld zu sein
sie hat natürlich noch andere
eigenschaften wie zum beispiel diejenige
süß zu sein ist also nicht die identität
wir lesen mal weiter warum sollte es
damit gut anders warum sollte ich wenn
gut gut ist sind undefinierbar gezwungen
sein zu bestreiten
lust sei gut hindert mich etwas daran
beides zugleich fürwahr zu halten im
gegenteil es ist sinnlos zu sagen dass
lust group ist wenn nicht gut etwas
anderes ist als lust es ist soweit ist
die ethik angeht absolut zwecklos zu
weisen wie spencer das war ein philosoph
seinerzeit es versucht hat das
steigerung der lust mit lebens steigen
und zusammenfällt sofern nicht gut etwas
anderes bedeutet als leben und als lust
es könnte eben er könnte ebenso gut
versuchen die tatsache dass eine
apfelsine gelb ist zu beweisen indem er
zeigt dass sie immer in papier verpackt
ist
was ist hier das problem
sagt man
genau das ist also am anfang wieder das
was wir schon gehört hatten davor
vielleicht lesen wir noch das nächste
zitat dazu und definierbares bezeichnet
wird auch weil sie sind jeder tag nur
zwei alternativen möglich entweder ist
es ein komplexes gegebenes ganzes über
dessen korrekte analyse
meinungsverschiedenheiten bestehen
können oder es bedeutet überhaupt nichts
und es gibt so etwas wie ethik gar nicht
im allgemeinen haben jedoch die
moralphilosophen gut zu definieren
versucht ohne sich darüber klar zu
werden was ein solcher versuch bedeuten
was praktisch benutzt benutzen sie
argumente welche die eine oder beide
ungereimtheit enthalten die wir in § 11
betrachtet haben wir können darum mit
recht schließen dass der versuch gut
definieren vor allem auf einer
unklarheit hinsichtlich der möglichen
definition sub beruht um die
schlussfolgerung zu sichern das gut
wirklich einen einfachen und
undefinierbaren begriff bezeichnet sind
letzten endes nur zwei ernsthafte
alternativen in erwägung zu ziehen
es könnte etwas komplexes bezeichnen wie
es bei pferd der fall ist wo das könnte
ganz ohne bedeutung sein aber diejenigen
die gut definieren wollen haben keine
dieser möglichkeiten als solche klar
erfasst und ernsthaft vertreten und eine
schlichte berufung auf tatsachen wir
dazu führen beide möglichkeiten fahren
zu lassen
das ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen klarer
was sagte am ende also was geht jetzt
hier nicht
mich jetzt zwar alternativen gibt es
wenn wir den begriff des guten
betrachtet er sagt er am ende
das hat auch ganz am anfang des zitates
zum nächsten oder bist du genau
er wird aber jetzt sagen ganz am ende
eine schlichte berufung auf tatsachen
wir dazu führen beide möglichkeiten
fallen zu lassen
also möchte eben nicht gerade nicht
definieren
er möchte gerade nichts sagen dass das
gut etwas ist was ich definieren lässt
im sinne seiner teile
er möchte auch nicht sagen dass damit
gemeint ist dass es bedeutungslos werden
es muss also einen dritten weg geben
jenseits dieser alternative und wie
sieht der jetzt aus wir lesen weiter die
hypothese eine meinungsverschiedenheit
über die bedeutung von gut zu eine
meinungsverschiedenheit über die
richtige analyse eines gegebenen ganzes
stellt sich sehr leicht als unzutreffend
draußen wenn wir überlegen das bei
jeglicher angeborenen definition
angesichts des definierten ganzen stets
zu recht gefragt werden kann ob es
selbst gut ist um einmal eine der
einleuchten darin weil komplizierteren
vorgeschlagen definition zu betrachten
man könnte auf den ersten blick leicht
meinen das gut sein soll bedeuten kann
wieder sehen zu sein was wir zu begehren
begehren wenn wir nach dieser definition
auf einen konkreten fall anwenden und
sagen wenn wir aber gut halten so
glauben wir dass eines der dinge ist die
wir zu begehren begehren dann erscheint
uns dass unser satz recht plausibel
also was versucht er jetzt zwar eine
definition des guten anzuführen
schauen sie mehr die mitte dieses
zitates was für eine möglichkeit gäbe
ist gut definieren
es sagt
das gut zu hören
genau hier
ok
und jetzt sagt er wenn wir alten zu
glauben wir dass es dinge ist dass wir
zu begehren begehren dann erscheint
unser satz recht aussieht
hören sie das auch so sehen dass gut sei
etwas mit begehren zu tun hat
brauchen
das gute aber es beginnt zu schreiben
oder würde man da nicht sagen ja bitte
also wird er sagen haben entstehen
das würde dann wieder ihren die plateau
in die aristotelische richtung geben mit
dieser technologie mit diesen tellers
mit diesem ziel natürlich gut hier ist
jetzt noch nicht das moralisch gute
gemalt hier ist einfach nur der
gegenstand eines strebens gemeint könnte
auch das böse sein zum beispiel
und fast das jetzt das gute angemessen
wir müssen weiter lesen was er dazu
sagen wenn wir aber die untersuchung von
uns fragen ist es gut zu begehren dass
wir agieren das wird nach kurzer
überlegung klar dass diese frage selbst
geben so einsichtig ist für die
ursprüngliche frage ist gut
wir fragen gründen nur nach genau
derselben informationen über das
begehren arzt begehren nach welche wir
vorher bezüglicher selbst fragen aber
ebenso klar ist dass der sinn dieser
zweiten frage ohne verfälschung nicht
auseinander genommen werden kann so ist
der wunsch da zu begehren eines der
dinge die wir zu begehren begehren
nichts was wir uns vor augen halten ist
so kompliziert wie die frage begehren
wir zu begehren dass wir a zu begehren
begehren wie das ist ja eine
wortspielerei wurden sie daraus ein
bisschen schlauer aus diesem zitat das
kann man jetzt herausnehme es ist
zugegebenermaßen recht kompliziert was
er sagte
was das problem jetzt
mit diesem begehren
es geht um das verhältnis zwischen
begehren und gut
dazu
stimmt
es ist
das hört nie auf und er sagt auch hier
in der ersten zeile wir können uns
fragen ist es gut zu begehren dass wir
agieren
ja
erstmal
genau genau also was vielleicht damit
praktisch zeigen was was ist seine
stoßrichtung jetzt hier mit begehren und
gut was wir damit prozentig zeigen
offensichtlich doch dass wir mit diesem
begehren eigentlich nie den sinn von gut
erfassen können dass wir eben dann immer
noch von jahre ist sie sind gut wenn wir
es jetzt begehren weil dieses begehren
hilft uns nicht
das gut zu definieren oder zu erklären
oder
weil wir eben immer noch fragen ist das
gut also diese frage wäre nicht
letztendlich redundant oder überflüssig
und wir können dieser fragen sinn
abgewinnen die mir fragen ist das team
gut ist hoffentlich so dass dieses
begehren nicht den ganzen sinn von gut
erfasst
m
also ist es gut zu begehen das
ratsbegehren dass die zweite frage von
diese können wir jetzt nicht so
auseinander nehmen wie ist der wunsch zu
beginn eines der dinge die wir zu
begehren begehren diese frage hier ist
es gut zu begehen das für agieren ist
nach ihm nicht dasselbe wie diese frage
also wir können einfach nach
gm nicht gut durch begehrenswert
ersetzen das ist offensichtlich punkte
wir können eben immer wieder fragen ist
es denn eigentlich gut also gut hat
immer noch eine priorität vor dem
erstrebenswerten von den begehrenswerten
der punkt wäre denn er könnte dann bei
erstrebenswerten immer sagen es ist
verheißt lust es ist es führt zur
luststeigerung oder befriedigung
er würde sagen ja aber ist das denn gut
ist die lust sind gut und würde immer
diese frage ist sind gut stellen wir
würden immer wieder sagen ja diese frage
ist berechtigt ist gut alles gut ist
immer noch eine stufe höher als diese
ganzen anderen naturalistischen
kriterien die er jetzt hier anbietet und
das deutet wieder darauf hin dass dieses
gute hier einfach so ein
transzendentaler also auch ein bisschen
transzendente begriff ist der ist nicht
immer weltlich letztendlich realisiert
sind wir bewerten mit ihm ein weltliches
und da scheint er mir jedenfalls eine
gewisse nähe zu plattform zu kommen was
eine ganz andere stoßrichtung heraus
natürlich ist kein unter loges
sprachphilosoph aber das endergebnis
scheint recht ähnlich zu sein
mit dieser idee des guten
mehr lesen noch mal weiter übrigen kann
sich jeder durch eine nachprüfung
schnell davon überzeugen dass das
prädikat des folgenden satzes gut
wesentlich verschieden ist von dem
begriff zu begehren begehren der in sein
subjekt eintritt dass wir begehren
sollen art zu begehen ist gut ist nicht
einfach gleich bedeutend mit
das 1 0 ist
das irgendwie dem text ist gut
möglicherweise ist zwar was wir zu
begehren begehren immer auch gut
vielleicht mag sogar das gegenteil wahr
sein aber sie ist sehr fraglich ob dies
der fall ist und allein die tatsache
dass wir sehr wohl wissen dass was diese
fragwürdigkeit bedeutet er weiß klar
dass wir zwei verschiedene begriffe vor
augen haben
also das ist noch mal hier
aber der punkt wir können immer wieder
fragen ist das gut können dieses gut
immer wieder dran hängen ans ende und es
ist jedes mal nicht so dass wir das
gefühl haben das erübrigt sich diese
freie nachdem kurz stellung das ist gut
es einfach vorgeordnet gegenüber allen
anderen versuchen es zu analysieren
durch begehrenswert und so weiter und so
fort
die untersuchung fortführen und fragen
ist es gut zu begehren dass wir begehren
soll wird nach kurzer überlegung klar
dass diese frage selbst ebenso
einsichtig ist für die ursprünglich
frage ist arco die frage im grunde nach
genau nun nach genau derselben
informationen wo das begehren harz
begehren nach welcher wir vorher
bezüglicher selbst haken aber ebenso
klar ist dass der sinn dieser zweiten
frage ohne verfälschung nicht
auseinander genommen werden kann ist der
wunsch zu beginn eines der dinge die wir
zu begehren begehren nichts
das hatten wir schon mal nichts das wir
vor augen hatten ist so kompliziert wie
die frage beginnen wir zu begehren dass
wir zu beginn begehren es hatte schon
genau das haben wir jetzt kommt ein
neues zitat jeder versteht sehr wohl die
frage ist dies gut wenn er daran denkt
ist sein geisteszustand anders als wenn
er gefragt würde ist dies lustvoll oder
erwünscht wurde bewährt abruft es hat
eine eigene bedeutung für ihn selbst
wenn er vielleicht nicht erkennt woran
worin diese eigenheit besteht so oft er
an inneren wert oder eigentlichen wert
denkt oder von etwas sagt dass es
existieren soll
hat er das einzigartige vor augen die
einzigartige eigenschaften gingen was
ich mit gut bezeichnen
jedem ist dieser begriff stets
gegenwärtig obwohl er sich vielleicht
nie vergegenwärtigt dass er von anderen
im bewussten begriffen verschieden ist
auf eine rechte ethische erziehung ist
es äußerst wichtig dass er sich dieser
tatsache bewusst wird und sobald das
wesen des problems klar erfasst ist
sollte es nicht schwierig sein die
analyse so weit voranzutreiben was sagte
jetzt hier nochmal über den begriff des
guten
gesundheit
der sieht sich auszeichnen
genau
was sagt er noch
gab es am anfang
wie begegnet uns dieser begriff des
guten
die frage dass und seiner geistes zu
schauen
die möbel sind
ich dachte jetzt an dass das der uns
einfach immer verständlich ist halt
nicht also das ist gut
er hat eine bedeutung für uns der
begriff selbst wenn ich genau wenn wir
gar nicht diese eigenheit selbst richtig
nachvollziehen können als er mir war
bewusst oder bekannt dieser begriff des
guten er hat zwar sehr unmittelbares das
sehe ich sagen so grundlegend dass alles
das einstellen
an der geisteszustand recht glauben
wunderbar
für
hier als er hat einen anderen zustand
als wenn er gefragt ist diese lustvolle
oder wünscht oder bewährt würden sie dem
alle zustimmen dass das sie immer noch
sagen würden ja gut wenn das lustvolle
ist er prüft ist verjährt ist sieht man
auch was anderes als das gute irgendwann
würden sie das fest machen warum ist
etwas anderes her
bruder punktgenauer ja dass noch ein
guter punkt dieses gutes intuitives
wichtige punkte das will er damit sagen
jeder versteht dass jeder es hat eine
eigene bedeutung für einen intuitiv wenn
man auch gar nicht genau rechenschaft
ablegen kann warum ist das ist auch noch
ganz wichtiges intuitiv das geht auch
ganz stark in platons richtung
jedem ist dieser begriff stets
gegenwärtig obwohl er sich vielleicht
nie vergegenwärtigt dass er von anderen
im bewussten begriff schieden ist das
ist dieses intuitive ist eine wichtige
qualität 9
genau wir schauen noch weiter
dieses mal hier diesen weg werden wir
mit der überzeugung beginnen
das eine definitions font gut gefunden
werden kann so beginnen wir mit der
überzeugung dass gott nichts anderes
bedeuten kann als eine bestimmte
eigenschaft von dingen und unser
einziges anliegen ist dann
herauszufinden was für eine eigenschaft
das ist wenn wir jedoch erkennen dass
soweit die bedeutung von gut reicht
alles mögliche gut sein kann
beginnen wir mit viel größere
aufgeschlossenheit
abgesehen davon dass wir wenn wir eine
definition zu haben glauben unsere
ethischen prinzipien überhaupt nicht
logisch verteidigen können sind wir
außerdem noch viel weniger in der lage
selbst unlogisch gut zu verteidigen
wenn wir beginnen mit der überzeugung
dass gut dies oder das bedeuten muss und
neigen dazu die argumente unseres
gegners entweder misszuverstehen
oder sie mit der entgegnung
abzuschneiden das ist keine offene frage
die bedeutung des wortes selbst
entscheidet sie eine andere
betrachtungsweise beruht auf einer tour
es ist es offensichtlich falsch sagt er
jetzt hier das boot nichts anderes
bedeuten kann als eine bestimmte
eigenschaft von dienen
die wir sowieso eine checkliste abhaken
können liegt das gute vor
so ist es nicht zu verstehen wie jetzt
eine bestimmte qualität ist jetzt dieser
stuhl 20 kilogramm schwer
so das ist nicht dieselben vergleichs
ebene mit gut einer weltliche
eigenschaft ist eine sehr weite
bedeutete die jetzt mit größere
aufgeschlossenheit in verbindung und das
deutet wieder rauf darauf hin dass
dieses gut einfach nicht jetzt immer
weltliches ist hier sind dass es
irgendwie tanz in den tanz oder
transzendieren wie auch immer jetzt und
geht das ist letzte stardust er noch
lesen unser erstes ergebnis hinsicht
dieses gegenstands bereichs tätig ist
also es gibt einen einfachen dessen
jetzt die kritik an einfachen
undefinierbaren nicht analysieren
gegenstand des denkens auf den hin sie
umrissen werden muss wie wir diesen
einzigartigen gegenstand nennen das gute
natürlich ist gleichgültig so lange wir
klar erkennen wasser ist und dass er von
anderen gegenständen verschieden ist
das ist es gut alle würde die gewöhnlich
als bezeichnungen ethische urteil gelten
beziehen sich darauf und sind nur
deshalb auszüge ethische urteile weil
sie sich darauf beziehen
aber sie können sich in zwei
verschiedenen weisen darauf beziehen
welche unbedingt auseinanderzuhalten
sind wenn es darum geht eine
vollständige bestimmung des bereichs
ethischer urteile zu bekommen
bis dahin noch mal ein paar sänger zieht
das jetzt noch mal wenn er sagt alle
wörter die gewöhnlich als bezeichnungen
ethische urteil gelten beziehen sich
darauf auf diesen einfachen
undefinierbaren nicht analysierbar
gegenstand und sie sind nur deshalb
auszüge ethische urteile weil sie sich
darauf beziehen
das ist doch jetzt mal ganz interessant
auf hier kommt wieder ein philosoph ins
bild der den wir ganz zu beginn hatten
hier pate gestanden zu sein scheint
da scheint mir auch zu sein die idee des
guten die idee des guten ist der science
grunderkenntnis und der wertgrund alle
anderen ideen erscheint das jetzt auf
das ethische zu beziehen also alle
anderen ethischen begriffe im bereich
des der ethik die müssen auf dieses gut
hin irgendwie fixiert sein auf diesen
begriff guten und dieser begriff des
guten ist eben einfach nicht anders ihr
bar
das hat ganz stark was an der idee des
guten bei platon nur jetzt hier bei ge
sprach philosophisch und nicht mehr
unter logisch es geht hier allein um die
verwendung des begriffs gut wie können
wir ihn sinnvoll verwenden und den
zusammenhang
den zusammenhang ethischer begriffe mit
einem solchen undefinierbaren begriff
darum geht es geht also um dieses system
es gibt ein system politischen begriffen
die alle mehr auf die sonne hin
orientiert sind und das gute ist sagt
die sonne das gute ist letztendlich die
ethische uhr einsicht die ethische
orientierung
das ist der grund alle ethik diese
letzte bezugspunkt haben wir können
immer wieder fragen aber ist das gut
wir können dann angenehm beim nützlichen
bei diesen ganzen und militaristischen
termin immer noch fragen aber ist das
wirklich gut und die tatsache dass wir
immer noch dieses ist das gut anhängen
können zeigt dass das gute über allem
steht das ist ein fluchtpunkt ist auch
das alles hin zu läuft zum orientiert
und deswegen ist eben das gute nach 10
uhr begrifflich nicht in dieser welt
jetzt zu finden sondern eben außerhalb
so als ein fluchtpunkt und das scheint
mir ziemlich nahe an plattform zu kommen
eben nicht nur ökologisch sondern sprach
philosophisch ja wir haben wir uns jetzt
sehr viel mühe gegeben durch diesen
zugegebenermaßen sehr schwierigen text
durchzuarbeiten aber ich denke wir
konnten gerade anhand des letzten starts
schön sehen dass es doch bisher neuen
plattform steht in der nächsten sitzung
werden wir uns mit für die pacht
auseinandersetzen da wird noch einmal
die fragen im wesentliche rolle spielen
wie verhält sich die natur das seien zum
sollen gibt es in der natur schon
anhaltspunkte dafür dass sollen zu
erkennen sie bringt es mit der
gesundheit ins den vergleich also dass
gesunde dass das normal
sich verhalten die in der natur das ist
ein beispiel des guten
wir müssen diese these ganz stark
problematisieren und dann haben wir noch
eine sitzung der werden wir dann zu
einer abschlussdiskussion kommen dann
bis zur nächsten sitzung